[Music]
YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do -
one two nine three one five seven three
one that is my texting community
platform doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there and also access
opportunity first looks in that
environment
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch the reason that everybody should
make a tick-tock video is not because
you have a product selling to 80 year
olds and there's 12 year olds on the
platform or that you want to really the
real reason is to get your kids super
upset but but yeah but the real reason
is you got your perspective
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how much are you how much are you
addicted to accountability 100% yeah
everything in my life is my fault yeah
I'm I'm a I weightless I really believe
that we have to make accountability cool
and that like I'm starting to believe
and I've been throwing it out there I'm
starting to believe that if we make
accountability cool in the same way that
we view being politically woke in the
same way in entrepreneurship that we
view the grind in the same way that we
view watches in the same way that we
view activism and giving back you know
all these things that I just mentioned a
decade ago not cool like it just it
wasn't everything I just mentioned 10
years ago 15 years ago not in the
consciousness accountability leads to
maybe you're miffed at your mom right
maybe I've helped you through my content
to say actually it's your mom who's your
problem but then when you take that and
actually put it on a shelf and say yes
but it's my accountability to accept it
or not then when you deploy empathy and
say yeah but her mom did that to her
all of a sudden you don't resent your
mom even though you had the Epiphany of
like [ __ ] that's the problem and you've
taken on you which then allows you to
get light it's fun to not resent your
mom anymore because who wants to really
and then you start chipping away at
accountability and like you just change
the framework it's acknowledging it you
have to know it's in the room but it
goes to not blaming that because that
becomes the crutch and the excuse your
full control I believe if we make
accountability supercool it will lead to
enormous amounts of happiness
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys just in a podcast start to this
day Jason that are talking it we really
hit on something which is let's make
accountability cool I'm starting to
realize that accountability actually
leads to so much of my happiness and I
think I'm gonna start beating that drum
similar to empathy and other things I
think I'm gonna see a lot more
accountability talk which is gonna be
uncomfortable because people hate it but
I think there's really something there
and I'm gonna try to navigate those
waters what are you a disco girl sorry
you're like a disco girl do you know
that the disco girl - 14 year old
teenage girls have totally taken over
the one out the white-on-white Air Force
Ones you don't know about this you're
gonna have to really change up your
sneek again it's true no I just um that
was not [ __ ] on you that's me trying
to help it's not Rick Ross anymore
it's visco girls community good morning
as I look at Madison Square Garden and
the Empire State Building up I'm gonna
leave you with a tidbit judge the judger
always think about who's given you the
advice or the feedback hey guys sorry to
interrupt your video I'm just giving you
this call for my number to let you know
that you have to join my text community
to one two nine three one five seven
three one hit me up with a text the
context is have been Fleming about to
speak here on s AP is alive on the
Internet as we speak
idle ahjumma we have no idea what the
[ __ ] we're about to talk about but I'm
being fireside chatted which is always
my favorite because I just answered the
questions oh and best commute ever s AP
happens to be in the same building as us
so we just had to go down the elevator
to go back up the elevator we're on the
twenty-fifth floor this is the 45th
48:48 good save good save good save
a decision yes I shared that with my
daughter the very sweet 16 yes
Wow her like it made the difference
burger she's so timid about what she
wants to do where she wants to go and
like yes I get it you inspire her thank
you for saying that thanks for sharing
it's it's it's I'm so good with words
but there will never be words that I can
put - being on the receiving end of that
sentence it's just those were the actual
words right is that what I know what you
guys would think again you articulated
what you say you couldn't act it there's
a very meta event thank you for saying
that yeah it's really it's fun it's
really fun and you know it's what's
really fun about what you just said is
actually my process by me reading so
many direct messages from 16 year old
girls from 21 year old guys it's how I
even knew to go there so it's really
very fun to like go through the process
of being an anthropologist strategist
listener to becoming a prolific speaker
and how it just kind of works just
starting their businesses I have family
coming with me
my niece and nephew just starting a
fitness business Ramon we don't have a
lot of money any tips you can give them
with a zero money or little money how
they can start yes I think about two
core things in my macro thesis of
underpriced attention which ads are
actually under priced for what they
return in business results not reporting
results and which platforms are giving
us free organic reach that over time may
lead to awareness right now the two
greatest platforms in the world for
organic reach of scale are tic toc and
LinkedIn
now tic toc ski is extremely young so if
you're selling to 54 year old CIOs tic
TOCs not necessarily going to be the
place to go but if you're starting a
fitness app tic TOCs an incredible place
to go it's really ironic you know we're
sitting in a moment of time and I have
not seen this in the last decade where
one mature platform and one extremely
young emerging platform are the current
state of organic reach at scale
so that's the answer to that question
but there's other things there are sales
DNA I think every single person starting
a business that has no money needs to
take out their cell phone go into their
address book
and literally text every person there
whether it's their mom or somebody they
talk to once correct and say look and
this is the nuance do you know anybody
not will you buy my product do you know
anybody who might be interested in my ex
I think you'll get two or three answers
and I think people are scared to ask and
when you have no money you only have the
ability to ask your thoughts on social
media and digital advertising overall
and to have the big guys and gals jump
into it our cost going to be different
is going to be harder for smaller
businesses what do we need to understand
about more and more companies shifting
demand when you're saying shifting their
ad knowledge to digital how does that
affect other businesses in what should
we know about it well this is why I keep
yelling at the Davids of the world when
Goliath comes and spends money on a
platform that is completely supply and
demand of how much money's in it and as
an actual marketplace not a floor of
cost of inventory that is what people
need to think about like the reason to
be early is no different than the reason
to be early in real estate we're sitting
here in Hudson Yards we were here four
years ago as a tenant that was a better
price per square foot than it is now
because this is all built out that's
right so you know that's how I think
about the end consumers awareness
organic reach on Facebook six years ago
when I was screaming at the top of my
lungs was remarkably low and that really
helps small businesses as larger
businesses come in and start spending ad
money the cost of getting into the
stream goes up it's like everything else
Superbowl used to cost a lot less when a
lot less people watched it this is just
applying to man it's always supply and
demand and yeah this is why the LinkedIn
and tik-tok conversations so important
because when you don't have the luxury
of big media dollars you have to look
for those angles or even when you have
some media dollars you have to look at
things like Instagram swipe ups or
heavily targeted YouTube pre-roll to
understand where there's scale to move
your business but an underpriced net
cost on the actual attention consumption
not the potential reach but the actual
reach
no pressure and I did my first tick-tock
video by the way just a few weeks ago
I'm very proud how'd it go by the way
real quick
just to bring value the reason that
everybody should make a tick-tock video
is not because you have a product
selling to 80 year olds and there's 12
year olds on the platform or that you
want to really the real reason is to get
your kids super upset but but yeah but
the real reason is when you create for
the platform you may find a nuance there
that you learn that three years later
matters for your business and
storytelling on a platform that does age
up and uses that nuance I think that I
did well on Instagram and snapchat and
now tick tock because I pot committed to
vine seven years ago and picked up on
the nuances that I now still use
creatively so the learnings of making
video in that way and that form becomes
skillsets that you may deploy when maybe
LinkedIn evolves it's video product and
has some of those nuances so I helped
piece together some of the questions
list that they just made one of the ones
I totally had an interest in wasn't at
the democratic debate one of the largest
conversation pieces was bringing up the
major yes
I'm kind of unemotional if they get
broken up I'll have to look at the
capabilities of the platform's you know
what's amazing about being 100% consumer
centric if you told me the Internet has
to be shut down right now I'd be happy
to do direct mail newspaper radio and
television ads so my thoughts are I
don't know you know from a marketing
standpoint I really don't care I'm just
prepared to adjust to the reality
instagrams organic Reach drop is a far
bigger concern for me then if it got
broken up separated from Facebook that's
political conversation that's pandering
to the macro conversation of the
demonization of technology that's gonna
play out
however plays out and whether
did they get these companies get broken
up or not it's not really something that
even comes to my mind I'm a date-rape
day-to-day underpriced marketing
attention and if those platforms aren't
able to achieve the best deal then I'll
find the thing that is I just need to if
they said that Facebook can't have any
data to target people then it becomes
television please think about social
media like TV yes it make old
communication of nice yes yes I think
you know what you're talking about I
think most people are putting out
content in a traditional way yeah and
don't respect the platform they're
distributing on those videos were made
for television this is a different
medium and we have to make content that
fits the medium that we're distributing
in and most people don't think about
context they think about production
value on content and that is the
enormous mistake of the far majority of
people that are producing content both
individuals and the biggest companies in
the world from Carroll to coca-cola it
is the mistake the elevation of
production value of the content and the
disrespect for the context of the
platform its distributing it on okay
many practitioner and Italian
entrepreneur are very concerned about
the handling of haters haters yes and
you have some advice is better I have an
answer no yes ignore nothing your answer
is off and he's akin ignore 90 answer 1%
of the time because you're busy ignore
99% of time zero percent of the time
delete never delete ok because deleting
it gives it more power more importantly
let me leave everybody with this zero of
your haters will be by the bed when
you die zero of the haters will be at
your Christmas dinner zero of the haters
you know we we lose loved ones we lose
to death loved ones we mourn them for an
hour a day a week and then we move on
with our lives we remember them we hold
them dear but your parents your children
god forbid your best friends
you mourn them for a week if you're
deeply in love and then you remember
them forever to live your life based on
a stranger who you won't even know
anything about this is a very bad idea
it has less to do about the hater it has
to do with the person's own insecurities
[Music]
how are you price is easy to have me
I don't like agency people that's
actually weird true answer Roy we are
about to hit a chapter right now where
we really need especially actually in
all functions but for strategy and
creative I need less agency people
because we're building a model that's
upside down and all I want a veiner
besides kindness as a macro in the micro
of the actual work is ideas and making
and you don't have to have worked at an
agency to be talented enough for ideas
or have the humility to be good at
making so this is really exciting
chapter for us because a we're very very
much focused as an organization to
create a enormous push of diversity
inclusion with any organization that is
just ultimately I decided all the things
I was doing for last three years and
empowering executives wasn't getting
done so I just decided to become a
dictator of it that's why this is
happening that's why I have many other
things happening so Eric was hired like
they're like we're doing it at the same
token it's when we need to hire people
that don't need to have agency
experience thus were not at the mercy of
the agencies industries lack of it so
it's it's good [ __ ] timing right
[Music]